let's see what lessons we can learn
about editing from this year's five
best editing oscar nominees and then
take a look at which one deserves to win
this video is sponsored by curiosity
stream
in the trial of chicago 7 this character
tom hayden
is concerned about the way two other
characters abby and jerry are behaving
in court this conflict is set up very
briefly at the beginning of the first
big courtroom scene
whatever's going on between you and abby
would you keep it out of this building
and it comes to a head in the next scene
abby you cannot talk back to the judge
and jerry but even though this conflict
is never mentioned verbally again
throughout this scene besides the quick
mention at the beginning
it plays a crucial role throughout the
entire scene
are you familiar with contempt of court
it's practically a religion for me sir
there are other arcs of conflict and
drama in this particular scene
but this one plays an important role and
is kept
alive throughout the entire scene
entirely through
editing with the use of well-placed
reaction shots editing is about the
relationship between images
the images you choose to put next to
each other and when you choose to make
the switch
is one of the most powerful tools in
films toolbox
for creating meaning in this case
placing certain shots of tom displaying
certain emotions
directly after what another character
says or does
creates in the audience the impression
of a reaction and we see meaning in that
reaction
meaning that helps develop the conflict
between the characters
and that tells the story if we move
these reaction shots around
and place them in other spots within the
scene we could tell
an entirely different story seated at my
table as my boss u.s attorney thomas
ferrand i guess you could say
i'm seated at his table creating
different meanings
and a different impression of the
characters every cut places images into
juxtaposition these two shots create
meaning in our minds because of the
relationship we infer between their
content
what's happening in each shot but shots
also relate to each other temporally
spatially graphically and rhythmically
the temporal relationship of two shots
is
how much time we perceive as having
passed between them
frequently you want the temporal
relationship between two shots to be
continuous
like this cut from promising young woman
look because don't be mad just i'll get
the check
the audience is meant to perceive this
cut as just a change in angle
there's no time that has passed between
the two shots
the one is just a linear continuation of
the other but sometimes you want to use
a cut specifically to indicate that time
has passed
honestly i thought i'd be bored out of
my skull
watching the kids but it's still great
actually
here there's a clear temporal distance
between the two shots
instinctually we just know time has
passed because the type of alcohol
they're drinking has changed and there's
now
food on the table where there wasn't
before these two shots and the cut
between them places specific emphasis
on the alcohol though which is important
to the story of the scene but in
addition to the tempura relationship
these two shots
also have a graphic spatial and rhythmic
relationship graphically the two shots
are pretty different
one is visually pretty simple center
framed and has a human subject
and the other is a lot more visually
complex while the subject is also framed
to the left these two shots also have a
rhythmic relationship
this shot is static while the
conversation is pretty
slow and awkward and this shot is
dollying back fairly quickly
marking the increased pace in the
conversation and the scene imagine
for a moment if the editor instead of
cutting from here
to here had cut from this shot
to this shot one that is graphically
spatially and rhythmically much more
similar
to the first shot technically we could
still tell that time had passed if we
were paying very close attention
and saw that the wine glass had changed
but most likely we'd be confused if this
was the choice of cut
for such a big temporal jump
we can see another example of a very
similar jump in time in the father
here again we go from a wide shot of the
characters
to a close-up shot of food on the table
that is
moving you'll notice again that they're
very different spatially graphically and
rhythmically and the focus of the shot
on the transition
the chicken is again important to the
scene like the alcohol
all these big changes together help
create a transition
that makes the temporal jump between the
two shots feel more natural but here's
where things get really
complex clever and interesting when it
comes to editing
sometimes you want to confuse the
audience
in this same scene in the father editor
your ghost lamprenos
uses two very graphically similar shots
to intentionally confuse us
at the start of the scene we see this
moment where anthony walks in on
a conversation believe me the doctor is
right
the moment will come when however good
she is he's
ill man he's ill
dad what are you doing standing out
there come come on the scene progresses
they eat dinner
anthony gets up and goes to the kitchen
he walks back
and we see this he's ill and
he's ill
dad what are you doing standing out
there come come and sit down the scene
feels like it's been progressing
linearly but then a
moment of dialogue and action seems to
repeat
dad what are you doing standing out
there come come on dad what are you
doing standing out there come
come and sit down it's leaving us
confused about what's happening and
when it really happened graphically
rhythmically and spatially
we feel like this should be the same
moment but
temporally it doesn't make sense it
shows the audience directly
what anthony's experience of dementia
might feel like for him you might have
noticed that i'm now talking about the
relationship between two shots that
aren't directly beside each other in the
film they're spread out on either end of
a scene but that's another layer of the
beauty and complexity we find in
editing that the relationship of two
shots can create meaning
even when they're spread out and not
connected directly through a cut the
sound of metal uses the graphic
relationship between
two shots spread out over the entire
film to create meaning
first shot of the film is reuben sitting
at a drum set
not speaking i'm not going to show you
the other shot in this relationship
because it would spoil the film but
think about that just showing these two
shots side by side would be
a spoiler for the film that's how much
information is
conveyed just in the relationship of
these two
images creating a strong graphic or
rhythmic callback to
another earlier shot highlights a moment
in our minds and we focus in on what's
going on
in that moment the graphical
relationship between multiple shots
spread out across a film can also help
create a sense of rhythm and the sound
of metal using this specific shot
twice to establish the morning after a
concert
creates a rhythm that helps us
understand that this is the character's
routine we then feel the disruption to
this rhythm as the characters lives
begin to change and conflict is
introduced into the story the same
technique is used in nomad land in the
first act there are several very similar
tracking shots
following fern as she's walking roughly
the same amount of time
passes between each of these shots and
it helps create a rhythm that again
is disrupted as the story begins to
progress editing is essentially a series
of
decisions about what relationships you
want to create between
shots each decision creates meaning that
helps tell the story
so how for a best editing oscar do we
even begin to judge which editor is
making the best decisions for their film
critical to the sound of metal working
is its ability to place us
inside the subjective perspective of the
main character
as he begins to lose his hearing i
already talked about in another video
how sound design was used to create that
perspective
audibly but the editing plays a massive
role in making the transitions between
limited hearing and a full range of
hearing feel
natural and make sense to the audience
take for example this scene where the
audio moves from
ruben's limited hearing to a full range
of hearing
the movement between these two
perspectives doesn't just happen it's
cued by a cut
this cut is timed with a sound within
the environment
and the transition both visually and
audibly between perspectives
feels seamless the same thing happens
here in this scene he's having trouble
even communicating with me
it is
wider shots like this which show us more
of the world around
ruben are usually linked to a
perspective of full hearing
while more subjective shots like this
that are more close up
contained and focused on reuben himself
are generally linked in the film
to ruben's subjective experience audibly
the editor is using
a big change between the shots
graphically and spatially
to cue a big change between the shots
audibly
you're not going to hear a blender
generally if you're not showing one
on screen so to some extent the editor
is choosing and arranging
what sounds are going to happen where
the editor has to be thinking not just
about the visual relationship between
two shots
but also about the sonic relationship
that might exist between the two shots
once the sound design is finished to
avoid spoilers i can't really talk about
some of the best edited scenes in this
film but there are so many moments
where the characters emotions aren't
conveyed
through dialogue it's the performances
combined with
the rhythm of the editing and the choice
and progression of shots
that creates the emotion and some of the
most significant
moments in this film
the trial of chicago 7 is acclaimed
writer aaron sorkin's second foray
into directing and his direction is fine
but
nothing about his direction seems to
have the same unique
voice that he has as a writer except
maybe
in this film the editing look at how
sorkin is writing these lines of
dialogue
no place to be right now but in it but
fry the pigs
dr king is dead there's an overlap one
line is a continuation of
the other now sorkin can do that not
just in the script and in an individual
piece of dialogue
but between scenes if we're met there
with violence
you better believe that we're gonna meet
that violence with
non-violence always non-violence and
that's without exception chicago 7 is a
film that really trusts its audience to
just
comprehend its narrative it moves
quickly between ideas
scenes flashbacks and the films present
without doing much
hand-holding for the audience and this
allows a lot of freedom
stylistically within the edit to
maintain a pace
that matches sorkin's dialogue take a
look at this moment where we jump from
what's being talked about on the witness
stand to a flashback of that event
did you have a meeting on that day yes
uh with whom
mr hoffman and mr reuben is it abby and
jerry's fine
and what was said at that meeting here
there's a jump spatially temporally and
graphically
and there is no establishing shot to
orient the audience or even a moment of
transition
to show us we're in a different place
instead we're left to infer what we're
seeing from the dialogue the clear
rhythm
of the edit here is what carries things
through
just look at how the rhythm of the edit
and the dialogue are working together
through this moment to carry us out of
the courtroom into the flashback and
back into the courtroom they also said
that there would be public fornication
say that again sir public fornication
you're asking for a parks permit for
public forum
rock music no of course not what if it
was r b
did you issue the permits no i did not
once the film
establishes this pattern it gets even
more complicated cutting between
multiple versions of the flashback and
the courtroom scene
seamlessly it's a pretty impressive feat
and these choices move us
deftly and quickly through a complicated
story with
a lot of different moving pieces all
while keeping up with the breakneck clip
of sorkin's dialogue
is there anybody there
if the trial that chicago 7 trusts its
audience with its narrative
the father places immense faith in its
audience
the father is a 97 minute film that
feels
much longer
it has a narrative that often leaves you
confused about what's really happening
but this is entirely intentional
everything all right
who are you sorry
who are you the film is attempting to
put you inside the experience of a man
with dementia
it does this by carefully managing and
manipulating the information that the
audience has access to with most of
what's really going on
in the larger plot merely hinted at your
husband
who your husband
my husband this is a delicate balance
too much confusion
and the audience could get annoyed or
frustrated and not enough
and the film's concept doesn't sell as
hard and the story doesn't have as much
impact
look at how this scene withholds
information from us with a well-placed
cut
and you're going to have to what
while simultaneously emphasizing the
importance of the information we don't
get to hear with the same cut
there are two elements of this film that
are very important the passage of time
and the location as a character an
editor jorgos lampernos deftly manages
both of these elements in the edit he
uses a rhythm of
editing and pattern of shots to
establish both the location
and to show that time is passing
the payoff here i can't talk about
because it's spoiled the film but it's
powerful
and it wouldn't be as effective if those
moments weren't as precisely edited the
editing here is quite masterful and
subtle in a way that i think is
a little unusual for an academy best
editing nomination
sometimes a restrained but precise hand
is better than a bold and stylistic
approach to editing
speaking of bold and stylistic
approaches promising young woman has a
very specific
energy and tone that is important to the
story
[Music]
the energy and the tone aren't just
stylistic elements
they're critical to what the film is
trying to say
quantifying a film's energy and tone and
where it comes from is difficult to do
here the set design performances camera
movement sound
music and most importantly for us
editing all work together
to create this energy pacing is maybe
one of the most important elements of
energy
in a film and pacing is primarily
controlled by
editing look at how the rhythm of the
music and the edit works together to
seamlessly transition us between three
locations
[Applause]
sometimes it's the lead-in of the
dialogue carrying us into the next scene
without dropping the pace
you know i was talking to graham earlier
and he says and sometimes it's even the
fully
and the sound design making the cuts
feel more abrupt
signifying not just a change in location
or scene but
a more significant change in the
character or the story
yet again some of the most significant
editing choices are
in spoiler territory here but i can say
that sometimes the choice of when not to
cut
is the most important choice an editor
can make
and if you've seen this film you
probably know what i'm talking about
nomad land stands apart from the other
nominees this year for
a specific reason writer and director
chloe zhao was also the editor of the
film
zhao has talked about how she thinks
about the editing in the writing
and shooting process doing all three of
these things herself allows the editing
to
truly start in the screenplay and the
writing to end
in the edit and while this is true of
almost
every film the fact that she is directly
doing all three
gives her a unilateral control and you
can see that
come through in the final product joules
work is stylistically linked to
terence mallix
oh that's almost a whole bag of doritos
and his more free-form
impressionistic style of editing has
clearly been an influence
that style isn't just something that
happens in the editing bay it's a style
that's
grounded in a unique approach to both
production
and editing you'll notice that a lot of
what i talked about at the beginning of
the video doesn't
really apply here in the same way there
are big jumps in time within a scene
without it being clearly marked
take a look at this scene which is
composed out of just four shots each of
which
jump pretty far in time
editing like this where the relationship
between shots spatially and temporally
is
a lot looser is a technique that
sometimes we call
montage
we often think of a montage as a quick
succession
of images that skip through time with
music playing underneath but nomad land
following in the tradition of malik and
some other filmmakers
kind of blurs the lines between montage
editing
and more traditional styles of editing
here's an example it's called wet and
dry
we need it to be wet ready
[Music]
and then we need to mask the fender off
because the white paint will land on the
fender
too put plastic over this you can see in
the scene that there are big jumps in
time that
are really meant to be covered over
they're pretty noticeable but this
also isn't like a traditional montage
there's dialogue there's no music
and even though we're jumping forward in
time with different cuts the scene
doesn't actually cover that much time in
total
editing like this is a very different
approach there are less rules and it
requires a strong
just intuition for what is going to work
there's a beauty and a power to create
meaning in this type of editing that
draws people like malek and zhao
to this style for the types of stories
they want to tell
i think this is certainly the most
uniquely edited
film out of this group of nominees and
it really showcases what's possible when
you
edit in a more free and unconventional
way
so who deserves to win best editing out
of this group of nominees
i think it's a tough choice this year
none of these films are poorly edited if
i have
a critique of any of them i think the
trials of chicago 7
while it's well edited maintains a
breakneck
pace almost too much i wanted more
breaks and more variety in the pacing
and the rhythm there i wouldn't really
be
upset if any of the other films won best
editing but
who would i personally choose as the
winner one of the biggest deciding
factors for me
is finding a film that isn't just using
editing to help tell the story that's on
screen and in the dialogue but a film
that is truly telling important parts of
its story
with the editing itself for that it's
almost a toss-up between nomad land and
the sound of metal
in both of these films there are moments
where dialogue takes a back seat
and the significant emotion is conveyed
through well-timed cuts at very critical
points
in the story personally i think i'd
choose the sound of metal for the win
but i'd be very happy
if nomad land got it as well what do you
think which of these nominees
uses the relationship between images to
tell its story best
when i edit videos for youtube
unfortunately i can't just focus on
which images
will best convey what i'm trying to say
instead i have to think about what will
avoid a wrongful copyright claim or what
will help the algorithm promote my video
in almost all my videos the version you
finally watch on youtube
isn't my original cut it's a version
that's gone through several revisions to
make it more youtube friendly it's kind
of like having a robot producer looking
over your shoulder in the editing bay
that's why i'm excited to tell you about
nebula where i don't have to worry about
those things and where you can watch
the original extended director's cut of
this video
nebula is a streaming service created by
myself and a bunch of other great
creators
including other great video essayists
like lessons from a screenplay
patrick willems and like stories of old
so we can put our videos somewhere
without having ads and without having
youtube looking over our shoulder on
nebula instead of listening to this ad
you could be listening to the big long
tangent about why the trial the chicago
7
score is terrible that i had to cut out
of the video but what does any of this
have to do with curiosity stream well
curiosity stream has partnered with us
to provide
nebula for free when you sign up for
curiositystream curiositystream gives
you access to fantastic
educational documentaries covering a ton
of topics i recommend
obit which is about the obituary writers
at the new york
times you can get access to that the
extended version of this video and
everything else on curiositystream
and nebula for 26 off the annual plan
when you use the link in my description
it's less than 15 a year you get access
to all of curiosity stream and nebula
all while supporting my work and the
work of other independent content
creators so
click the link in the description to
sign up or go to curiositystream.com
thomasflight using that link helps
support my work and gets you access to
more content
like this ad free